- [Instructor] This right here is a map
of the Persian empire in 490 BCE,
before the Common Era.
And you see that it is
an extensive empire.
It was established by Cyrus the Great
and then this successors.
We talked about it in previous videos
how they were able to conquer
the Neo-Babylonian Empire
in 539 BCE and then go on to conquer
much of the middle east.
They were able to conquer the
long-lived Egyptian empire.
They seemed somewhat unstoppable
at this point in 490 BCE.
At this point, we have Darius is ruler
of the Persian Empire,
the Achaemenic Empire, as
it's often referred to.
And they're able to keep expanding
until they come across some unexpected,
unexpectedly resistant people,
and that's the Greeks.
This is probably one of the most famous
and legendary stories
in history, the rivalry,
the conflicts between the
Persians and the Greeks.
You should maybe take it with
a little bit of grain of salt,
because what we know of it,
the history that I'm about to give you,
comes to us from Herodotus.
And Herodotus who's often
known as the father of history,
he was Greek.
And he also lived after a lot
of these conflicts happened
and he wrote about these conflicts,
his adult life was well
after these happened,
so he had to talk to people
who were around that time
and obviously, he is getting
the Greek side of the story.
There are no surviving
Persian accounts for it,
so you might want to take
it with a grain of salt
because the accounts of Herodotus do tend
to make the Greeks look pretty good.
But let's just talk about what happened,
because taking it with a grain of salt,
it is a fascinating series of stories.
So you have Darius as king,
you can see the extent of
the Persian Empire in 490 BC
or really at the turn of the century
if we were to go back 10 years to 500 BCE,
but they are in control of some folks
who are are a little bit more rebellious
than most of the people that
are within the Persian Empire.
And they are in this
region right over here,
known as Ionia, where
you had Greek settlements
that are now under Persian control.
From 500 BCE
to about 494 BCE,
so kind of the first 10 years
of the fifth century BCE,
you have a series of revolts in Ionia.
Let me zoom in on that a little bit,
so we can see that,
you can see our timeline,
right over here.
So this area, we're now zoomed in,
this area is referred to as Ionia.
This would be modern-day,
the coast of modern-day Turkey.
We're out here on the Anatolian Peninsula.
And these rebellions in 498 BCE,
the rebels are able to take
over and burn down Sardis
which is under Persian control.
The Persians under Darius
are not happy about this.
So they send a force to,
to take back control
and also to get a little bit of revenge,
because when the rebels were
able to take over Sardis,
they had help from some
of their Greek brethren.
It's important to note
that the the Greeks weren't
some type of a unified state.
They weren't a unified Empire
like the Persians were.
They were a fragmented
group of city-states.
You have the famous
Athens, Corinth, Sparta,
all of these city-states,
they shared a common language.
They shared similar religion,
but they were not one unified Empire.
But when their brethren, the Greek rebels,
these Ionic rebels, I guess you could say,
rose up against the their Persian rulers,
they had assistance from Athenians
and from folks in Eritrea.
So when Darius finds out about this,
not only does he want to take
back what the rebels had,
he wants to suppress them,
he wants to put down that rebellion.
He also wants to have
revenge on the Athenians
and the Eritreans.
So the first thing he does
is he sends out a fleet in 492 BCE.
You see his fleet here in green.
This fleet that I am tracing.
He sends it out in order to in order to,
in order to seek revenge on the Athenians
and the Eritreans.
But he is unlucky and once again,
these are the accounts of Herodotus.
His fleet, his large
fleet, runs into a storm
and is mostly destroyed,
and is mostly destroyed.
And so in 492 BCE, the
Persians are unsuccessful.
But they are not satisfied.
Darius is not happy with that idea
that we are the largest empire known,
we should be able to take
on these fragmented Greeks,
with a much smaller population,
much less wealth than
the mighty Persians do.
So in 490 BCE,
he sends out another attempt to take over,
to seek revenge
and to subjugate the
Eritreans and the Athenians.
This time he is a little
bit more successful.
His fleet is not destroyed.
So this is in this brown color,
I'll try to color it in.
This brown color right over here,
you can see the path
of the fleet this time.
And he is eventually,
he is able to subjugate
and take over Eritrea,
but as he's going to Athens,
which you can see right here,
they decide to stop at Marathon.
That word might be familiar to you
and we'll talk about
in a second why it is.
That is where they're
engaged by the Athenians.
The Athenians are able
to defeat the Persians.
This is a very big deal in history.
Once again, this is Herodotus' account,
but up to that point, the
Persians seemed invincible.
But now the Athenians were able
to actually destroy them in a battle.
And the Persian fleet, they
go back to their boats,
they run back to their
boats according to Herodotus
and many of them are killed
as they as they retreat.
They're going to go back
around the peninsula,
potentially to go attack Athens.
but they decide not to and they retreat.
Now the word Marathon,
this is a very big deal
in history first of all,
is that this mighty empire
is put back in this battle.
It oftentimes, historians will mark it
as the beginning of a
kind of Greek ascendancy,
the ascendancy of Greek civilization,
at the end of these Greco-Persian Wars.
We're really just in the
beginning periods of right now
that's really the beginning
of the Greek golden age.
But as we'll see, the Greco-Persian wars
are not over with the battle at Marathon.
That was just the first major interaction
over the next few decades.
Now one thing that you might be saying is,
hey, that word marathon,
that seems familiar.
Maybe some of you have run a marathon
or you want to run a
marathon going 26.2 miles.
You might say, is there any
relation to this battle,
to this location in
Greece called, Marathon.
The simple answer is, yes.
So there's an apocryphal story,
and when people say
apocryphal, they're like,
"Well, we're not sure
if it really happened,
"or maybe it didn't happen."
And this one, people are
pretty sure it didn't happen.
The story goes something like,
when they had the battle,
a messenger was sent
from Marathon to Athens
and the distance from Marathon to Athens
is roughly the distance
of a modern marathon,
around 25 or 26 miles.
The apocryphal story goes,
they went to deliver the
message of the Persian attack
and the success of the Athenians,
and then when the messenger
gave that message,
he just passed out and died.
So when the modern Olympics
that we've set up now,
over the last hundred and something years,
they said, "Hey, let's have an event
"that celebrates that run
from Marathon to Athens."
That's where our modern
marathon actually comes from.
Now the actual story as
best, as I can figure out,
and I encourage you to
look up primary documents
to figure this out for yourself,
is it's mixing up a few stories.
After the victory at Marathon,
the Athenian army did quickly mobilize
and go back to Athens
and cover that distance
in order to defend Athens.
Because remember it looks
like the Persian fleet
were coming around this
peninsula right over here
to get to Athens.
The story of that runner is
there was runner named, Filipides,
who was sent from Athens to Sparta
to convey a message.
That's actually a much further distance.
In a lot ways it's much more impressive,
but those two stories
were mixed up together
into the story of Marathon,
which is where we get our modern-day
distance of the marathon.
Hey, let's all run roughly the distance
from Marathon to Athens.
In the next video, we'll see
that the Persians are not done.
Darius will not be able
to seek the revenge
that he wants in his lifetime,
but his son Xerxes is
going to keep going at it.